ghosts are real there's much I know
there's a general in Turin the movie is
crimson peak crimson big is not a horror
film is like nothing romance big
difference and Gothic romance mostly is
sort of this princess like figure
falling in love with a by Ronnie and our
gentlemen going to a crumbling mansion
which is a staple of Gothic so this girl
goes to that castle and discovers a
horrible secret this Gothic romance
depends on our building I thought the
best course of action was to build it
for real I think that digital effects or
computer effects should only be used as
the last resort we can put a great deal
of craftsmanship into creating a vital
character of the movie which is the
house we spend about seven months
layering the house visually but what we
did is we do a process that I I jokingly
call I protein as opposed to eye candy
because if the content of it is not only
beautiful but it tells the story so to
give an example we build that furniture
in two sizes 30% bigger 30% smaller so
when either his in the furniture and
she's weak she looks little and when
she's strong she looks bigger we color
code the movie very carefully so that it
has chapters in different colors I
wanted to color code the ghost
some of it is instinctive is
non-rational like I wanted to open and
close the movie with a black ghost I
wanted to have one white ghost and then
I said the ghosts are gonna be red and
we're going to link them to the clay
because the aspect of them I wanted them
for a very particular reason which I
don't want to spoil I wanted them to be
characters so as the movie goes on you
realise their function is different than
you thought I knew from the get-go when
we were doing the movie to be
female-centric because Gothic romance
was written by great women writers and
make it about two point two points of
view of love but either this one type of
love
Lucia is another type of love but one is
liberating
and they're only suffocating just really
just do very strong wheels clashing
full-frontal in Mexico we have a saying
we don't believe in ghosts but ghosts
are real
something doesn't matter what you
believe I experienced that all my family
seeing ghosts
I don't know it must be in the water